we often talk about being pause if as if
there's an honor in it right being
poised grinding let's release people
from that and capitalism has set many
more people out of poverty than any
other system we we yet know of have you
noticed that black people on the right
don't abuse black people on the left but
black people are left abuse black people
on the right yeah I mean we're not black
enough with the wrong kind of black
we're coconuts we've given in we're
slaves it means that white people on the
left feel that they could abuse you as
well so I remember I had a labor MP call
me a token
um token Ghetto Boy imagine a Republican
or a conservative MP Senator whatever
said those words people would be calling
for their head you might hate your boss
but he was the one who risked the money
to make your job yeah it wasn't you you
could have as we explained to our staff
every day yeah we owe tons of money to
China where we should have probably
built that Financial partnership
elsewhere in the world with people who
are much more aligned with our thinking
who are much less out to dominate the
world I think the difference between
India and China say India want to be a
big powerful country they don't want to
be your boss China wants to be your boss
[Music]
hey Francis are you worried about
inflation
absolutely mate every time I dare it it
smells me right up that's bloating not
inflation what's the difference neither
is good for you and they both leave you
feeling devalued but absolutely
atrocious if you are worried about
actual inflation and need impartial
advice as to how to survive the economic
crisis than fortune and freedom is for
you fortune and freedom is published by
South Bank investment research and is
for the investor looking to access a
wide range of informed opinions on lots
of different investing opportunities
their brilliant newsletter covers
everything from causes and the impact of
inflation to the rise of
cryptocurrencies gold investing and much
more besides through their daily news
commentary and special reports fortune
and freedom can give you more confidence
in making informed decisions about what
to do with your money simply go to
Fortune freedom.com that's fortune and
freedom.com and sign up for a free
newsletter that will help your money
work for you the link is in the
description
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant guest today is a former
mayoral candidate for this very city of
London Sean Bailey welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
it's great to be here it's really great
to have you on man so I'll let people in
on a little bit of insight into how we
met we were doing TV together and we got
chatting in the green room and we don't
really have politicians on this show
because we don't believe that they're
going to be honest honest conversations
we don't think that's likely to happen
with a politician but you and I had a
very blunt and straightforward chat
about some interesting things and I
thought this guy's got some really cool
things to say and he's actually prepared
to say them before we get into them
though tell everybody who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life that leads you here
before I answer that question I'll tell
you why I'll tell you your audience why
politicians aren't real because we
punish them when they are true and
everywhere in the world we have the
politicians we deserve and if we want
better politicians we shouldn't punish
the ones who try to tell us the truth I
think that's an important thing in the
Western World in particular what we've
done is give so much of our
responsibility to politicians that we
then can get away with stuff like the
state of our children is not our
politicians fault that's our fault or we
need to take responsibility for that by
abusing them it means that we can we can
put our hands up and sort of walk off
and say it's not our fault and I think
it's really important that especially
younger Generations realize
you have to take responsibilities for
the world that you want if you look at
Britain for instance Britain is a great
nation and has been great for a very
long time it wasn't politicians that
made Britain great it's actually Civic
activity that made Britain Great and
Civic activity means that the civilians
in the peace have to get involved but
that's my right so just before you go on
though I couldn't agree with you more
it's the ethos of how we think about
these things as well and I think people
are now getting the sense of why this is
going to be a great conversation anyway
who are you apart from that so so what's
been going on in my so I'm a father of
two I'm married to Ellie I have Aurora
and Joshua of my children 13 and 15. I'm
a Londoner born and bred I come from
West London Ladbroke Grove around that
area
um I grew up in a single parent family
and we were very poor but very happy
um I never really realized I was poor
until I was sort of sort of into senior
school and then like because everybody
around was poor none of us had anything
and we were so ecstatically happy most
of the time I didn't realize it's anyone
went to school and started thinking I
can't afford a Kappa jumper those boys
are wearing pharaohs they're like Mom
could I have pharaohs absolutely not
you're gonna have the plastic School
trousers and you're gonna love them and
that experience was very important for
me because it gave me a slightly
different take on the rich poor thing I
I had much less Envy about it it just
felt like a problem that needed to be
solved I'd like to believe what's
driving me is good outcomes for people
I'm including myself and my family but
not just pure money because I think that
changes how you interact with the world
it delivers a different kind of fear and
I say all those things because that let
me do what I really wanted to do so as I
grew up I got very involved in youth
work I then went on and set up my own
Youth Work charity
and I was able to have the conversations
with my local community that the social
services and the local Council either
couldn't have or didn't know they needed
to have and I really enjoyed that the
greatest things I've ever done is family
therapy and basically I just delivered
people to family therapy my job Club
because it gave the people around me and
income to do with what as they pleased
and
I ran a football club I literally don't
know the rules of football even now but
what it meant was I could get at the
time which was our biggest issue to my
mind Fathers and Sons and by extension
families together to build their own
resilience their own stories to pass on
and I really really enjoyed that and it
looks like my community did but all of
those activities were what pushed me to
politics yes I'm an elected conservative
politician I stood for Parliament twice
I ran for mayor
um year before last but
if you I would like to believe if you
spoke to me for more than 30 seconds I'm
not what you think a conservative
politician is but actually I am what a
conservative is I believe in country I
believe in family I'm a church goer you
know I mean I pray and and run around
and sing hymns and all that jazz and I
do those things because I live in a
country where you're allowed to and I
believe that you should be allowed to do
that my neighbor is a Muslim I mean him
have great fun our neighbor across the
road is a Hindu and then we celebrate
all of our all of our holidays as well
and we do that because we're in this
country which is a western country that
allows you to do that my son who's who's
11 at times did something really great
to me he said I love to buy this and why
is that he says and have a party I mean
it's a whole idea that because we're
you know rolling around in other
people's culture we can take some of the
strength from from there and and I and I
like that and and but
I wasn't bothered in that situation
I grew to that situation through going
through life like my first Mentor was a
man called Baron Hume who was an
absolute socialist he's Associates but
he's one of the greatest people I've
ever met because he wasn't trying to
make me a socialist all he ever used to
do is point out why he's a socialist and
he used to ask me questions that he
thought needed solving poverty you know
redistribution and asked me how I would
want to solve them he challenged me to
do that rather than tell me his
political belief is the way and I
forever I'm grateful for that forever
grateful and what you were talking about
though is so interesting Sean because
you know you're a conservative
politician but I would think that if you
ask most conservative politicians what
conservatism is
I don't think they'd be able to answer
you and if they do give you an answer
it's not going to be an honest one well
let's check if I could answer
and look for me conservatism has two
potentially three areas that you need to
focus on one is the technical
conservatism small government freedom of
speech freedom of expression I believe
in things like marriage I believe in
things like education I believe in in in
in in in in
capitalism for The Meta term now do I
think capitalism has all the answers no
I remember a guy saying to me are you a
factor right no but I believe she did
the right thing in the wrong way making
a strong Community
um
both family and financial gives you the
freedom to explore things like
being poor
we often talk about being poor as if as
if there's an honor in it right being
poised grinding let's release people
from that and capitalism has set many
more people out of poverty than any
other system we we yet know of and
that's why I think conservatism small
government Innovation entrepreneurs
letting people keep their money all of
that stuff is important and if you flip
over to the social side I would say that
conservatism is about the responsibility
of adults if you see what's happening in
most of the Western World infantilizing
adults and by turn we then infantilize
our children even more the strongest
communities in the world have a few
things in common one is they're
financially stable two is they're far
away from the government they don't need
the government they're basically most of
their interaction with the governments
around tax
and and the law and I think thirdly they
take responsibility for the education of
their children now I don't mean you
should educate your children in a vacuum
but you should make sure your children
are being educated and you should check
and then you have the right to check
what that education is you know I
sometimes ride in the western world we
are taking all of that education into
the formal system which means that
parents have no say on how their
children educated which is wrong because
in our
tradition and in our legal system you
are legally responsible for your
children so therefore you should be
intimately wrapped up in what they're
learning
and so you touch on something that I've
been present to for a long time now
which is I kind of feel like whenever
anything happens in our country whatever
that problem is now we always now as a
society look to government to solve the
problem
and and I tell you where well that's a
problem so I had a very interesting
conversation with a guy on a bus I love
randomly speaking to londoners it's
great it's half the reason I ran for
mayor of London more people recognize me
and are willing to have that
conversation
and we were talking about you know what
what has the government done what is the
government down what is the government
dance we actually talk about drug dealer
is that and I said the government's
relationship with drug dealing is your
law enforcement
that's it why your relationship with
drug dealing is do you buy drugs do you
have the people in your family buy drugs
what about the children in the world so
I said then what have you done about
drug dealing in your area
and he said nothing and you see the Bell
go on in his head oh he's like ah what
do you mean exactly like it's we as the
adults in our own world and in our
children's life don't do something about
the privilege of drug dealing nobody can
nobody can and he said yeah you're right
and we had a big conversation about
nobody grasses and all this basically
exactly so if we're to save our children
and our neighborhoods from something
like that we have to do something about
that I remember when I I used to be
special advised to the Prime Minister I
probably should have mentioned that
I used to be special and advisor to the
prime minister in what era in in
Newfound crime and just across the piece
because David Cameron was very
interested in my take on most things
because he saw I I have no white middle
class skill which you know helps in
certain situations because I I'm looking
at purely from the effect and my
politics I'd like to believe is of
poorer people how do people who need to
work keep working get ahead have a life
so I I was often asked what do you think
about this should the government be
doing that and the government should do
plenty but it should always remember
that it's there to enable not deliver
and I used to say to David if if we seek
to do everything for families we will
weaken those communities the community
you come from David does mostly
everything for itself now we all think
that's because it has financial means
and that is true but it's also because
it adds to confidence and the historical
timeline of doing it itself because you
can get the poorest immigrant
communities in this country and they do
almost everything for themselves and
then you look at second and third
generation and then you have to figure
out how much has this idea that the
government should do everything
infiltrated that community and when
you've when you've indexed that you can
directly see how well and that Community
is performed so I'll give you an idea
the Indian Community generally
particularly in London is very
independent very go ahead and you've
seen that in there in their level of
sickness in their level of income
everything they are a strong cohesive
Community going ahead because they have
taken charge they haven't fallen into
that left-wing thing of well we'll wait
for the government to save us because
the government isn't going to save you
and the other thing I'd say to people
watching this no government has any
money it's your money your money not
theirs your money and when you view it
in that way it makes you ask different
questions
in my world I would send everybody a
bill
right of what the government has been
paying for with their tax return right
and see how happy they are I I bet you
the public would ask significantly
different questions
and you say that you don't have white
middle class skill which means that you
can approach subjects and I'll say
probably a far more honest and objective
way
what does white middle class Guild stop
us seeing or stop us D what problems
does it stop us dealing with effectively
the generality of white middle class
skill means that you're so busy from a
right from a from a sort of place of
trying to help trying to do things for a
community that you wouldn't do to your
own you know and you you make Provisions
for a community that feel good but you
don't have that problem in your
community so I'll give you an example I
remember when Tony Blair changed the law
that your 14 year old daughter could
have an abortion without you knowing
that is
absolutely mental mental mental mental
you're responsible for this child
morally physically legally they're going
through one of the biggest situations
that any human being can go through and
they're allowed not to tell you so if
your daughter got out of that monster
should look in school your scrimmer gets
to get to school she's had an abortion
you don't know I mean come on but the
reason he could do that because someone
had convinced them all that you know
children are sexually active things
these happen you can't Lumber them with
a child but he hadn't realized that the
children his community that doesn't
happen to them he had children in other
communities it does happen to them and
by divorcing them from their parents you
increase the likelihood that that will
happen you don't decrease it so it's the
difference between dealing with the
symptom or or the unintended
consequences of something that you've
done
I mean when black lives matter came to
prominence right white middle class
Guild meant that white people didn't
scrutinize what black lives matter was
about a Marxist organization and that's
great if you agree and you've looked at
it and I remember when I said I'm not
really on board here black and white
people freaked out and I distinctly
remember and I used the word a brother
stopped me in the street because he said
it to me that he's a brother and why I
liked the way he approached me because
he was basically saying look as black
people we need to come together we've
got a fight here I said that's great but
do you feel like these people are
forwarding a fight I said what do you
mean I said as far as I'm concerned if I
had a magic wand and could do anything
for any Community particularly the black
community I would strengthen family
structure
family as you know the sort of 2.4
children version of it is the single
strongest financial institution we've
ever had on this planet thus far mental
institution as well and quite frankly
fun everybody black white young old gay
straight come from some version of a
family in a black community in
particular particularly in Britain our
family structure has been decimated more
than 60 of black children grow up in a
single parent family and that's
important for many reasons but one I'll
highlight is if you come from a single
parent family you're that much more
likely significant more likely five
times more likely to grow up in poverty
right so for me that's that's enough of
reason to try and eradicate that here
forget what others and I said on a black
lives matter website their stated aim is
to destroy the nuclear family and I said
to them do you agree with that
and he looked in my boat he was stunned
because believe me he knew his stuff
because he was coming from a place that
I recognized of righteous black and I
get that I understand that
but he he just he was like well what
does that mean I said it means what it
says on the tin and unless somebody else
says it means something different
I can't support that because you and I
know that we collectively and
individually we do better if our family
structure better so why would they don't
understand our problems or their goal is
not for us but either way I'm not on
board
and his reaction to me
was so
emotional
that he made me feel like this because
he didn't tell me I was right but his
reaction made me feel confident because
in the newspaper I was being destroyed
on that he but it is a case of
sometimes in public life you have to be
brave so the decision is do I be brave
do I hide
or do I absolutely just you know join in
and this for me was so important
I kind of decided to be brave but he
gave me the opportunity to test to go a
bit further with that because then
subsequent weeks months and year I was
continually asked the question because
obviously people are now trying to lose
that to trick me up because black lives
matter was gaining great prominence but
what was interested in what was really
interesting to me black people would
question me about it they wouldn't just
destroy me so those who just destroyed
me about it
they were never coming my way in that
instance they were never going to vote
for me but I was into it was a sort of
80 20 thing 20 people just immediately
destroyed you 80 of people wanted to
know why and I think myself and other
people challenge about lives matter has
changed what they've had to do and
change people's orientation to it
it's really really interesting Sean the
the point that you were making there
the thing that I don't get is just when
you see an a black person or an Asian
person well basically an ethnic minority
come out and espouse conservative values
and say I'm conservative this is the way
that I think
the racial abuse that they get from the
left
is is worse than anything that I've seen
in years and bear in mind I grew up in
London South London in the 80s so I've
seen one race when you know BMP popped
down the road and you know getting to
going with my cousin to watch a football
we got Chase because he's brown I've
seen that
but yeah
I mean where do I start I remember
someone so I've had if you watched my
Twitter feed I remember someone from the
Press writing a thing about Twitter and
racist again on Twitter and she said I
looked your Twitter feed and I'm
astonished you get as much racist abuse
from black because you do why she she
was stunned by this and I said there's
two ways of looking at this right one a
black person who's desperate to rent
your you know rent you sort of
emotionally in a direction knows that
our race in the context of Britain in
the context of Western world is very
important to us because it has defined a
great deal of our history
and another black person won't realize
that they've been trained to do it by
people on the left so I remember saying
to a group of students have you noticed
that black people on the right don't
abuse black people on the left but black
people are left abuse black people on
the right yeah I mean we're not black
enough with the wrong kind of black
we're coconuts we've given in we're
slaves
and and and there was a bit of a
revelation in the room and then
everybody's testing it trying to prove
it and try to find people doing it and
all the rest of that and I said look
it's the kind of really Insidious
powerful racism that makes black people
useful idiots because what white people
can do they can stop us as a group of
people having any kind of decent
conversation right because they can get
you to tell me that I'm the wrong kind
of black or I'm not black I don't
understand what is to be black why what
black people should be able to do is
what white people do Russians Spanish I
don't know Italians everybody does
they'll have a conversation about
themselves and about anybody else
without the influence of other people
and and having that conversation has
isn't as that is an ongoing cross to
bear an ongoing cross debate it's been
it's
it's
left a real big footprint in in my
public and political life because what
it also means is
it means that white people on the left
feel that they could abuse you as well
so I remember I had a labor MP call me a
token
um token ghetto boy yeah imagine for a
second anybody watching this right who
understands you know
um conservative labor politics or maybe
Republican
um and Democrat politics imagine a
Republican or a conservative MP Senator
whatever said those words people would
be calling for their head yeah she said
it's fine but why it's really really
disgraceful because what it says to
young people black or otherwise in the
in the public sphere as it says if
you're black yeah don't you dare
go towards the right if you go towards
right we will separate you from the
people you love and care for so what it
then means if you're black it's much
easier to just keep to yourself not
exposing those you're adding Cuts black
people are from
half of the sort of political Theory and
belief systems in the world and I'm one
of those people who think
no one system has it all right so
therefore you need to scrutinize them
all to cherry pick and they're cutting
you off from half they don't have the
right to decide how you think that is
terrible yeah absolutely terrible I I
agree completely and Sean uh
uh it's funny you were talking right at
the beginning about things that you
don't often hear politicians talk so
much about which is Britain's a great
country that you're proud of and you
like and so on
and I feel the same first generation
immigrant I love this place I think it's
great in many ways and at the same time
we do have a lot of problems at the
moment too
so how do we how do we make sure that we
we are fulfilling on our potential as a
country
I think
the big sweep of it is to
in first place like ourselves my problem
with the public discourse that are left
now is all based on the fact that we're
idiots yeah the British goings-on
historical current and future we're all
idiots I remember someone telling me
that we can't have a British Bill of
Rights we can't leave the the ECR more
the rest of it and I have to point out
to them you see when the Europeans
wanted to do something around human
rights who did they call they're called
us they literally called British lawyers
we literally invented human rights now
you can tell me we may have had the
biggest need in the world human rights
but the point is we did and they trusted
us to write that bill it's largely done
by British judges and lawyers we did it
so the idea that we have somehow
forgotten that and we won't know what to
do when we're on our own is utter
nonsense actually it's a good chance
we'll do a much better job actually
that's actual block will happen because
we'll have much less influence and all
the conversations we're having about
um representation of women
um gender representation excuse me um
LGBT race and that we are basically the
only people in the world having that
conversation correct there is no one in
Korea or or Japan or even places like
Italy or or France they're not doing the
hand ringing we are and what that shows
you is it's a live issue for us it
probably always will be a love issue us
but we do the work we make the progress
and that's just one Arena and I say that
because we have to believe a little bit
more in ourselves
if you look at the nations in a while
like Singapore or Japan who are coming
even French to a certain degree they
think they're right they they largely
like each other French people Frank
France is great they'll talk about
French histories if it's great right we
need to step back and look at our
history and our history is checkered but
no more checkered than anybody else's
there is no Nation on this world that
has more than a Fiverr in its wallet
right that doesn't have things that you
could point to right I'm not saying we
have weird I'm not saying we pretend
they're not there but it's not a reason
to suggest that we're not of no value
and arguably we've recovered at the
greatest speed and have and have less of
a distance to go and I think you've got
to start there we like us because if you
don't like yourself it's hard to do
anything positive going forward and the
other thing is it's trust the system and
I go back to a statement I made early on
the greatest thing about this country is
our civil organizations yeah let them
test it let them go around and yes we
all hate politicians and we think
parliament's nonsense the rest of that
but actually our system is definitely
the best in the world
and the one
very very important thing about
adversarial system all ideas are tested
if you're in China and you're high
enough up the political you have an idea
that's it yeah here even if you're a
prime minister it
tested and if you look back at our
history it's probably why we've made
less lurching mistakes there's been less
self-harm of this country than most
because our ideas are tested and
sometimes I see people on the left who
want to shut down debate you know push
people out and I point them out if we
did that as a tradition you wouldn't
exist
because largely this country has been
conservative for hundreds and hundreds
of years and it didn't push out the the
the the more sort of left-wing socialist
debate they had it and that's why you
exist and that's why this country is
strong so if you push them out what
what's gonna happen what is going to
happen and you show me any individual
any philosophy Any Nation or any
organization that's been right about
everything everything and I'll show you
a life
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you the ideal space
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew door's
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
well I agree with you completely and as
you know you've read a little bit of my
book which is we were talking about and
that that's kind of my message to people
here as well we've got to remember we're
good people we've done some bad our
ancestors did some bad things like
everybody else's ancestors but if we
want to have a positive vision of our
country we're going to have to believe
in ourselves for sure I think that's
really important and it's great to hear
you say it and at the same time we've
obviously got a lot of practical
problems happening right now we've got
we we our national debt is greater than
our GDP at a time when the government is
about to give away people more money to
help them with what is a legitimate
crisis you know in terms of the cost of
living and all of that how do you see
this playing out now with with the
particularly since 2008 when we've
printed so much money
we had record low interest rates we've
got a massive national debt now we're
having to deal with the war in Ukraine
the cost of living all of that how does
list trust survive let alone
that's right there's a couple of things
I'd say I think the world is up for is
in in line for a big correction our sort
of historic around about five percent
interest rate was workable it was an
interest rate that came from less debt
more interaction people and when I say
people I mean Nations the planet spent
what it had
um moved to the Fiat system great
amounts of debt Finance all the rest of
that and that just marching on
it called it's not sustainable yeah it's
not sustainable and and it's it's it I
remember talking to a kid at the bus
stop and trying to explain to him about
debt and what we're doing and and
elements of the environment and I think
look it's basically this you're on a
chocolate desert island and you have a
choice you can eat all the chocolate not
be hungry but drown or you could be
hungry but still have the chocolate to
stand on but you guys are balance here
there's a balance here and I think we
may have gone far as a planet not just
as a nation to too far one way
when you bring it down to the sort of
nation level
we are in as good a condition as anybody
to do with it I'd argue if you ranked
the world we'd be in the top sort of
five ten percent to deal with the
problem it's gonna be painful but
there's some big steps you can say
please stop printing money
the printing of money
I mean I've never quite
another question who gets that money
because I didn't get any of it
maybe if I've got somewhere I'd be a
little bit less against you know
stopping it but that's not true though
is it Sean we all got a bit of it
because we all got investment more
investment than there would have been in
education and health and whatever like
we are just living beyond our needs as a
country I tell you why I don't think we
got any of it because we're living
beyond our means everything that we've
got we're effectively gonna have to give
back well our children well yeah one of
the experiences of my life for a little
while I I I I had bailiffs I owed money
to people
and somebody said to me do I regret that
and my answer is no and the reason I say
no is because all of the debts I've
built up were to survive there was no
Ferrari there as I like to call it there
was no luxurious car there wasn't even a
flash coat in there right it was like I
was unemployed for a long time I was
homeless for a little while it was like
if I don't do this
I'm sunk here so I never regretted that
debt I wonder as a planet and as a
country could we say the same
and whatever happens my grandmother used
to say this you're gonna have to pay it
back you're gonna have to pay it back
you gotta so we should always be
planning our finances with that idea
that it's going to have to be back and
and I don't wish to be political it's
not my thing I have to be asked to be
political but on the left their response
if you see care established response to
the
cost of living crisis to the building is
a sticking plaster it's a it's an it's
gonna then need to be addressed again I
remember listening but it's the same
with less trust yeah but the difference
with least trust is the one functional
difference I think is important is
giving the economy giving individuals
giving business more of their money back
if you if you if you remember what I
said at the very beginning I believe in
entrepreneurs
entrepreneurs make the plan in the
broadest sense it's people who take the
risk it's people who say actually
I think we need rubber I know we could
get some rubbers people who say this
service will be of use to people who
actually put their own money in and by
giving people back their money like we
increased the propensity of people to
become entrepreneurs from a from a
spiritual level we let people know that
actually we appreciate people who take
risk there's a there's an economy to
bother taking a risk in from a financial
level it's worth you doing this because
you're going to get something back the
idea that we can all have the same
outcome with a different input
you might hate your boss but he was the
one who risked the money to make your
job yeah it wasn't you you could have to
as we explained to our staff every day
yeah yeah but this is the point and like
we found as we've done this as you know
we have employees now and we are
basically a small business this is what
the show is right
it's it's I'm not gonna lie to it's not
the easiest place to run a business but
but I I ironically it is one of the
easier places in the world if only
because we have our ability to raise
Finance but the one thing I would say I
I said also in the beginning I'm a
capitalist but I don't believe it has
all the answers and I I try to
set like this capitalism right works for
pound coins
its mechanisms deliver pound coins it's
the human inside that has to make that
coin do the right thing if something so
we see lots of businesses in the world
makes so much money right but not
involved in the profit the people who
made that money the staff and note that
I use the word profit because you can't
pay people if you don't have it yeah
right and one of the things that we've
done a lot of is use public money to top
up very poor businesses through tax
credits now if you receive tax credits
and I have in the past keep going I'm
not suggesting you stop that no but what
we should be saying to people is
you can only employ people if I actually
have a viable business we should make
that the law rather than topping it up
because they don't have a viable
business and a way to help people have a
viable business is what take less of
their money from them if you're watching
this now and you're a socialist
I get it I understand because your
social Vision makes you feel kind and
and there is elements of kindness in it
right again but the unkind part of
socialism is right the unworkable part
decision the crazy part of socialism is
where does the money come from
and I remember being at a debate with a
labor MP and he and I were just on
completely different ways if I really
knew and it was fine and he was very
decent man and we had a great we had a
great chat but he said one of the most
poignant things in a room that just made
my point for me he said every time
someone proposes a policy it should tell
us who not only where who they're taking
the money from and that's the point
isn't it because what happens in our Big
Rich Western World it looks like well
you can just charge the rich and in many
cases that might be right but what did
they do they then just cut off through
their employee and it does Us in I
remember speaking at a school and there
was a lot of um counselors and stuff a
little assaulting Tesco's and all the
rest of that you know Tesco's big
because they don't need me to defend
them but I said just just one thing
before you destroy Tesco's I know like
what's that I said they employ 300
000 people
so you destroy one business but how many
incomes you destroy I just I just want
you to bear that in mind I'm not telling
you Tesco's behaves ethically I think
particularly for small businesses they
should pay much more quickly than their
whole 90-day model but
we are all interlinked and socialism
often
you know picks out a villain soothes
them and doesn't realize the connection
that has to the rest of us and that that
for me is
I mean it's about education it's about
letting people know how money and
finance and economies work
Sean you made a very profound point at
the beginning of this interview where
you said we get the politicians we
deserve because we've destroyed
politicians who tell us the truth and I
really agree with you I think you nailed
it on that
we've got this huge debt and the reality
is our living standards are gonna have
to go down in order to pay for this debt
that's what that means what politician
is going to be able to tell that to the
British people and survive
none you can't do that I think it's
ironic because I think the last time
politics was really really honest was
austerity George Osborne basically said
if you vote for us we're going to
balance the books and that's going to be
painful or you can vote for the other
guy and um they vote for him and and
Cameron and why that's important because
I really do believe in the intelligence
of the Swarm the Swarm in this country
the vote in public there is an
intelligence there they do get it and I
think politicians and all of us are
relying on the public to understand
we've got it we've got to address this
ironically I think the pandemic
is helping people realize something
needs to be solved you know we dealt
with the pandemic if you agree with how
it was done whatever but people do
realize something was done it costs it
needs to be adjusted
um and also we need to have a
conversation about what living standards
are
because there's other things we could do
so for instance if
the amount of money you pay to live food
you know roof over you had more rest of
that
there's some places where a reduction in
cost is is
so much more useful than in another
place you know I mean like having great
amounts of disposal income is nice and
that's what people chase but actually
having lower cost housing is probably
much more important if someone said to
me an extra Grand a month that's fine as
long as my housing doesn't cost me an
extra 1200 pounds a month does that mean
and I think there's things the
government can do to lower the the
running costs of a person's life I'm I
mean when I was sofa surfing
one of the great Revelations for me was
this is about lowering my costs like you
know I mean like making my trainers last
longer I used to walk one way to work
and all the rest that I changed my shift
pattern so that I could walk at night
because it's just less hassle less
people whatever did you just I mean all
that colors are lowering my costs we all
know it effectively increases what
you're earning we might have to do that
on a national scale and that's what I
say ironically boris's plan around
nuclear and Liz is playing around tax
for me are two of the big
possibilities at repairing our standard
of living as quickly as possible but
it's I can't really see a version of
events where it isn't painful and Sean
this inability to be honest with the
public is this where this
counterproductive deeply irresponsible
policy of Western governments not just
in this country but particularly
somewhere like Germany I've been talking
about this for years man you can't make
yourself energy dependent on your
adversaries right but we've done that
we've done that in this country we've
done that Germans have done it lots of
European countries have done it why why
why why why of these countries our
Western countries made themselves
dependent on Russia why do we why are we
not energy sufficient we're shipping
factories and production to China where
they met all the same carbon dioxide
they just do it over there and we can
say we're green but look there's there's
two one is the broader piece of of
liberal arrogance so liberals believe
you know whoever these people are 10
minutes with us and they'll be liberals
too yeah yeah you know we'll just we'll
just tell them but you're wrong you're
wrong you know a starting a war and
taking territory doesn't work it upsets
people stop it stop it and we believe
they'll think oh we will run all along
why don't we do it that's the real thing
we you often hear in politics we should
be an example we should be leading the
way I really want to say to people right
who liberals nobody in Russia or
anywhere else in the world gives monkeys
about what we do we could be as green as
we like they're looking at the bottom
line they do not care what we do they
don't they might care about the green
issues but they don't care how we get
there they're going to get there their
own way simple as that and the other
piece was greedy so what people want you
to do was lower the cost of running
their country ship out some of the pain
so they could keep going back to their
populace and say look how wonderful we
are we're keeping your cost of living
down and um we're making you green yeah
and not really told the truth you see it
with someone at the Nordic Nations
swapping to
um geopower and have electric cars all
the way all over the place but they did
that through their oil money all the
money they have from their Sovereign
wealth fund was made in oil and they
made themselves green and there is a
hypocrisy there and you know that
self-congratulating liberal pat on the
back is is means that they won't
acknowledge something that's going on
and to make yourself energy dependent is
to make the people of your country poor
governments of all Stripes should have
spent more time building nuclear and
wind and and water and I want to be
clear to everyone if you're watching
this in your greeny right I want to be
very clear in the interim and that means
the next 30 to 50 years we cannot have
green power without nuclear
because when there's no wind
And when everybody turns their kettle on
because EastEnders is having a break
right yeah
solar wind won't cover that nuclear
power you turn it up about that and if
somebody telling you that that nuclear
power is dirty ask them what we're going
to do with all the batteries and all the
mining from from electric cars and solar
power because solar power wind power
will need some kind of storage that
means batteries that means some of the
most horrific chemicals we have on the
planet and when we're when we are
producing 20 30 million battery powered
vehicles a year what we're going to do
with all that waste and and it changes
how you how you look at your power in
the future we I I believe we can get way
way way down the line on fully renewable
power but the future is a long way away
and in the meantime you have a lot of
very poor people that you have to keep
warm and clothed now if you're telling
me your green credentials are worth more
than their immediate Comfort I think you
need to tell them that as well
it's it's a very good point we're
looking and we're seeing an energy
crisis and these bills that are coming
out are absolutely horrendous just to
look at we had Nigel farage in a few
months ago just before the Ukraine war
and he made the point he said I don't
think people understand what is going to
happen to them I really don't and it's
true
so who's to blame for that Sean in your
opinion for this is what we're seeing
now I'd say
the political firmament in general
across all of of Europe Putin has always
been
for whatever the enemy it's not like
last week he lost his temper and he
changed his motor Behavior he's been
like for a while
and I'm not sure why they thought it'd
be any different you know exactly
I when I was a youth work I dealt with a
lot of gangs
and it'd be like one gang saying to
another gang here you have our weapons
you hold our weapons and then let's
negotiate
well they have all the Aces and they
have and what's important is they have a
very fundamental Ace a very powerful Ace
and this idea that the rest of the world
will just
hang back while we deal with that no if
we don't buy that stuff fine somebody
else will buy it so Putin's not poor
because it's somebody else is buying
that gear and if you run another country
I remember somebody saying to me imagine
having 145 million mouths to feed of
course you're going to buy Putin's gas
who cares what what they think in
Westminster or what they think it is and
nobody cares because you're looking at
145 million people you need to feed and
and that's what we're seeing now and I
think in the Western World in Europe in
particular
you know from the second world war to
now we felt like we'd answered the
international
um system of behavior we felt like we
were so financially and militarily
Powerful that everybody would just do
this as we said and in our very honest
way we were also sticking to the rules
we it's not like we're saying you do
that and we did it we're all going to
stick to the rules no we're not it
doesn't work like that The Human
Condition doesn't do that and what
westerners had started to do is is
assume that people elsewhere in the
world felt the same about the outcome
felt the same about the future no and I
remember when they asked the Chinese is
that the interior minister or the energy
minister or something like that you know
about
um
his vision zero over 2015 all the rest
of that and he just turned around and
said you had 100 Years of the Industrial
Revolution it's our turn
and no matter how much
warm sweet words come out of China no
matter how much they're changing because
I'll change it quite a pace yeah that's
their driving force they're gonna have
their 100 Years of getting rich now if
they can do that and be green fine but
if they can't for them fine as well and
we see that I remember telling a green
activist she was saying the government's
terrible Center I said two things this
conservative government has spent more
on green relatively than any other
European government our CO2 output is
more than is less than half of what
Germany's is right so I I don't agree
with that and secondly we're less than
one percent of the word CO2 CO2 output
if we turned off
everything in Britain yesterday it made
no difference and then she said that
classic thing off but we should be
leading the way I said they don't care
what we're doing some of them are doing
a you know on a short pure Cash basis
they're doing better than we do China is
spending more on it but obviously
they've got more to do yeah the
Americans probably as well but at no
point in any meeting of any significance
have they said to themselves what are
they doing anything they're not they
don't care they don't care and unless
people understand that
we have to secure the poor people where
we are use some of our financial might
help the poor people elsewhere in the
world drive the conversation without the
idea that people are going to follow us
because that to other people also feels
like colonialism
um we we will make no decent impact for
the world hmm
the thing is Sean is that the thing that
I'm worried about is that we just keep
kicking this can down the road though
don't we that's the problem we're
continuing to kick it down the road and
nobody wants to have the very difficult
conversation
you're completely right but what I would
say the history of this country needs
must we will reach a point where we need
to do it and we will do it and I spoke
to a group of kids at a bus stop and
this boy is telling me about yeah but
like the world's in a mad States all
over Brad this time the other and I was
like let me tell you something let me I
want to give you a sonarity to go on and
I said what do you think it felt like
just before the start of the second
World War
so not only did they think the world is
over they then had a war a World War and
quite frankly it was over
he said yeah what's happening but they
recovered in fact they recovered to a
spectacular level if you'd said to the
people who went through the second world
war that we as a nation their
grandchildren and great grandchildren
would be the conditioner and now they
wouldn't have believed you the point
being this the human spirit is resilient
needs must will act when we want to act
the one thing where the green lobby are
correct yeah we've got to start having
the conversations and actions quickly
and I think those things have happened
but the problem is because we punish
politicians who tell us the truth
because we have a lot of the press are
all
it's sort of in extreme boxes so your
your guardian reader and everybody's
evil is on the right and we must sell
our children and make the world green or
you're on the right these people are
stupid and we should frack and nuclear
and everything right here right now
because we can't have Nuance
um complicated and developmental and
resolved conversations in the middle
that's what's slowing us down and the
other thing is well
how Finance everything has become
Financial so my reverence for
entrepreneurs comes from the fact that
if you go back 50 80 100 150 years
entrepreneurs produced things and
employed people and I don't think well
I'm not saying the service economy is
ridiculous but what we've done with this
service economy is made everything about
the end product the finance the profit
and when you build a business it has a
much bigger social footprint than when
you just Finance just fine and what
Finance did Finance in the Western World
particularly in this country has been so
successful it sucked a lot of talent so
there's people in finance now who in a
century gone by would have been an
engineer would have been a a a a a
doctor but now they're in finance
because they thought well most of the
astrophysicists that we produce end up
going into the city yeah yeah and and
that's a shame because it means they're
not answering some of the other big
problems that we as a country and we as
a world face and do you think that is
also part of the problem Sean in that
this is my opinion and tell me what you
think I'd say that our caliber of
politicians are some of the weakest I've
ever seen in my 40 years on this planet
so if you think about the factors if you
think about the Churchills if you think
about you know the former big beast of
politics well even blam Brown's yeah
gigantic compared to what we've got but
the reason there's two things I'd say I
think every generation laments the
people it's stuck with like Churchill it
doesn't matter where you are Churchill
did massive things right massive things
wrong but he was massive for the country
yeah at the time they treat him like
he's an idiot
I mean they got rid of him once I mean
so nobody loves the politicians they
have you know and that's that's just the
human nature I think the other thing as
well often a big problem gives you a big
hero if your biggest problem is what
color is your new car you're not a hero
in your home if your biggest problem is
you're poor and you get that job you're
a hero and and you can you can scale
that up can't you so I think actually
going forward we're probably likely to
see
more substantial politicians because we
are have more substantial issues to to
do to deal with love Boris will hate
Boris his response to the Ukraine was a
big deal it was a big deal and even if
you don't believe it the people of
Ukraine believe it which makes it real
did you just just I mean it's it's a big
it's a big deal so we'll we'll see and I
think
if Liz is the Hope For Liz is that she
makes enough of the change in the
Personnel for something different to
happen I think sometimes the the the the
immediate history of the conservative
party has been apologizing for not being
left wing enough whereas Liz seems like
she's going to be a conservative and
convince you that you should join in or
not it's a different it feels like a
different Paradigm Sean you mentioned
Ukraine do you think
that was a wake-up call that the West
needed to realize this Airy fairy world
that you were talking about how
everyone's gonna no I don't think it was
a wake-up call because I'm woken up you
are but most people were not no no no I
would be very clear it's not the wake-up
call that the West needed because they
didn't respond to it absolutely it's a
wake-up call but they needed to front
put it up properly
you don't think we've done enough no
what what you could well Putin's still
going
he needs look the Putin thing for me is
is powerful because pouting treating
Putin like like he's some crazy [ __ ] is
ridiculous he's been looking in this
direction for a long time similar
failing has been on our part we've kind
of antagonized the man he said don't
come east we promise not to come east
and then we go east So he responds and I
I mean in his mind that's a huge
justification for his behavior I'd argue
that probably done it anyway but that's
he he can he'd be sitting to me and said
but you said you weren't going to come
east what am I to do so so away he goes
and I
Putin was asked how would he defeat the
West now if Putin had said
I don't want to defeat the West that's
ridiculous then our reaction would be
fine but he said oh no he didn't say
that he said I don't need to defeat the
West they'll defeat themselves and what
that Comet shows you is interested in
the west being defeated so are China and
other places amongst in in the world and
our response has made that
it has kept that issue live it's kept it
going it's made it real if if you
something and Putin doing what he's
doing in a way in which he's doing if he
gets the outcome that he wants will
strengthen his position and clearly we
want to weaken his position and we'll
have to see another course there's the
ripple effect if you're China
you're probably thinking
let me see how to respond if it's a
strong response I might have to take my
foot off the gasket if there's a weak
response I'll charge straight through
the the the the the belt brace thing
what is called the China doing now I
mean that Dalton Road Belton Road excuse
me that is a really aggressive move I
mean short of
a military attack that's a single most
aggressive thing I'll just pause you
right there could you just explain to
people who don't know about it what it
is and also why it's so aggressive so
trying to have taken much of their huge
financial power and they've they've
decided to connect countries to China
which gives them control over those
countries financially and let's be clear
some of the contracts they're signing
with with you know countries in Africa
countries in the West Indies
um Sri Lanka all these countries tie
them tie those countries to China and
Chinese control I mean there's parts of
of the world where they're deliberately
trying to push out Western Nations and
block them in or or Circle Us in
um half the reason they haven't been
they haven't completed that is because
Nations like India have now had to sort
of push back because India is a huge
superpower in its own right and you
simply can't accept that but the West
effectively financed that we owe tons of
money to China where we should have
probably built that Financial
partnership elsewhere into all with
people who are much more aligned with
our thinking who are much less out to
dominate the world I think the
difference between India and China say
India want to be a big powerful country
they don't want to be your boss
it's a very different thing so I think
and just one tiny example so China are
building Railways in the world right and
if you're one of those smaller Nations
that's taken on Chinese Finance they're
financed you signed you up to an
expensive deal but here's the real thing
that shows you where China's headspace
are they've made the gauge of the
railways unique
so when you renew your stock you have to
go back to China
and what they're trying to do quite
successfully to my mind is build
dependency on them and that kind of
international control will mean they can
do all kinds of things it's why Taiwan
is constantly worried about its status
because China is showing that it's on
the front foot and then you look at
things like the development of
SuperSonic weapons nuclear weapons the
size of their Navy they are I'd argue
they're being aggressive now but they're
certainly giving themselves the ability
to be far more aggressive in the future
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets 2 million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your adword will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing at
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod DOT Co dot UK advertise with
us and we'll get your business canceled
Sean let's come back to Ukraine because
you said we should have fronted up to
Putin more in the past and look in 2014
the game was very clear anyone who was
paying attention would would have known
this was going to happen later because
he was just testing the waters and 14
right but what about now are we doing
everything we should be are we doing too
much too little I I I I think we're
doing too little I think we're basically
if you look at Russian history any war
that Russia has won has been for
attrition
and this the longer we just Where We Are
right Putin wins and he knows that he is
much more invested than winning that
than we are in not losing if he's I mean
we have to show that we're prepared to
really push back by energy dependency of
some of the major European powers France
and particularly Germany means that we
just can't we we we have
we have we we have lost before the
shooting started in in some sense we'd
have to be really Brave to win anyway
and that's why I say to people who are
like you know real sort of liberal
softies yeah they don't think like us
they're not like you they don't just
want everybody to get on and have a
lovely time they want control and
whatever they're going to do with the
control who knows but they want control
and ignoring them
um assuming that they'll stop
is giving them that control well as a
Russian I can tell you that's a hundred
percent true and by the way it's
probably true of almost everybody in the
world outside the anglersfield pretty
much yeah because in the atmosphere we
have a an agreement and we're
comfortable with our agreement and and
that's fine I it the mind boggles as to
why we think everybody else will be
comfortable with our agreement
it just
I don't care Sean you've got this lovely
down to earth manner about you and I
think it it comes from you know the work
the way you grew up your experiences
working with gangs
what did you learn when work when when
you were working with gangs because when
most people think of gangs they think of
you know I mean you could say older
people West Side Story but it's a media
image of a gang
it's not actually what a gang is like
so what I'm gonna
I think how I'm gonna answer this is the
emotional piece and I tried to give an
example be clear a gang is a business
yeah it's a business the currency is
money the difference is
um psychological bullying yeah and high
levels of physical risk yeah I remember
speaking to the police Minister he's not
please visit our kit my house he he's
moved on but
when I realized that he would be good he
started to get it is when he said to me
Sean what I'm planning to do do is
disrupt the business of might you use
the words business model of this gang we
were talking about particular gangs in
London and I said to him now you're
talking yeah because what we've been
focusing on is the crime
that is now you stop again gangs work
because they make money I mean you know
you I remember talking to a kid who's
trying to explain to everyone about um
Recruitment and again he said you've got
these Elders who recruit youngers
and they were like really you know is it
because your family's involved he said
no that's their job
and he said what do you mean and I said
look people who run gangs find young
attractive people
pay them to go and find young vulnerable
people to be foot soldiers
and they were like but sure I said
listen short of writing a job
description that's exactly what they're
doing they're driving around in their
cars and they think that kid's good
looking he's got the gift of the gab if
I give him a grand a month he can make
me 10 grand a month it's pure business
and when you are in and around gangs for
a bit you you you some people in the
gang understand that they tend to be the
sharper ones and tend to rise and the
other ones that they're still for poor
emotional reasons it can sometimes be
dangerous not to join your local gang I
I was asked to come and speak to a boy
um in Croydon who had got involved in a
life incident crashing at school really
good at school never end up and they
were like what happened
so I went to speak to him
and I was like this is a rule change in
your behavior he's like Sean brother
it's the only way to make sure they
leave me alone
I said like what does your local guy
have beef or something he said no it's
not a beef thing it's not I'm going out
and I have a kid to see me from an
estate is it rally let's get him it's
the kids on my estate they're basically
saying you're with us so you're against
us so it was like much less physically
dangerous to be with them and people
need to understand the complexity and
quite frankly the the
sophistication of gangs and when you
understand that they're human driven
organizations in the same way that
Google or Apple is yeah it helps you
understand why some people will always
concentrate on the emotional piece which
is very big you know they'll say because
it gives you membership of something
bigger than you and all of that's true
but you need to look at the whole spread
of gang
and I'll tell you a small story as with
David Cameron once and we were going to
a meeting and I don't want to give the
impression I hung around with it I
didn't you you know when I worked with
PM you could go like months without
seeing him like months but we went to
meet and he sort of Arts were briefing
what's going on all right we're going to
Treasury and I said like we're going to
get jumped here
is what he said actually I said because
you know when I say do you fight to do
against you see I said I said when
people are going to jump you don't
really look in the eye and this these
dudes are not looking at some eye and
you're the PM like let me look at that
he said yeah and I said they're all
being like
overly polite and and reserved if if I
mean that's when people spring stuff and
maybe came out to meet him and he said
to me so sure it looks like we've just
been jumped
I told you David and he said where'd you
get that from I said you know the funny
thing like that it's about gang Warfare
he said what do you mean I said this is
just a different game they're very clean
shaven well educated but they're a gang
they're operating in an emotional space
to promote their Collective belief and
and forward their Collective wants and
it's that's a gag mentality the only
thing is you can guarantee none of these
people are going to stab you
and he was quite fascinated he said he
said it's really funny and I was trying
to show him that he actually had much
more knowledge about gangs and he
believed he did because Eaton and all
that sort of which group your member of
who undermines who who promotes who much
of that is Gang that the special and
horrific thing about gang is bullying
and violence but most of it the personal
emotional politics people would
understand Sean you talk about
disrupting the business of gangs and
mostly that's drugs oh yeah
one of the things that I disagreed with
you most profoundly about was when you
were running from Air you you were very
strong uh on the enforcement and
Punishment of drug users side of things
whereas we've had a lot of people in the
show home but people like David Nutt for
example who who argue very strongly that
the best way to disrupt that is to
decriminalize the use of drugs to get
people who are addicted treatment and to
attack that problem from that end and to
take the money
out of the business of drugs what do you
say to that so let's separate yourself
what I did was focus on um white-collar
drug use yeah so I went on a building
site and his gears are there and and I
was laughing like because he he looked
like a boy I grew up with and I said boy
I grew up with you smokes too much weed
and we laughed in my life he said anyway
the drug test us all the time because I
dropped a crane
I said yeah and I filed a second why do
you get drug tested yeah because you
joined Ukraine and the guy doing um
everybody's pension doesn't get drugs
they said that's not right and actually
he buys shitload of drugs which is
driving a drug scene in London he should
get tested too I then found out American
Banks regularly do it so I just made
that suggestion because for me it's a
matter of parity it's a matter of
fairness if the Working Man in the
street is getting drug tested so should
the the one who works in a bank that
thing and there's lots of um what I see
is benefits that flow from that because
drug use destroys your mental health it
creates a market that my people are
actually dying for you know they
literally getting murdered over it so I
was right let me tell you why David I'm
sure he's a lovely man but let me tell
you why he's entirely wrong two really
big reasons
everywhere in the world they have
liberalized drugs yeah what's happened
is the legal Market has not gone away
it's actually grown what's happened is
you get a parallel legal and illegal
drug Market go together and because
drugs are legal here you then start to
lose people into illegal Market because
let's be clear imagine you legalized
weed in this country right marijuana to
the uninitiated
the government cannot sell you skunk
they cannot sell you something that's
going to blow your mind destroy your
lungs
um destroy your mental health and kill
you so what they'll do is you're gonna
show you vodka vodka is more harmful but
vodka takes time and vodka had history
on its side yeah if you invented if you
invented liquor tomorrow yeah it
wouldn't be legalized in a way it is now
and if you want to talk about alcohol
what's the single most dangerous drug in
in circulation that we're planning today
legal illegal drugs any drug
League of wise
I would have thought something like
heroin a Christmas alcohol yeah for
everyone heroin added it and it is
probably a hundred and fifty well it's
because alcohol is legal in myself but
that's the point it's legal that's the
point I'm trying to get it's legal it's
easily available price pushed down yeah
all the rest of that what would an
entrepreneur do if they could legalize
weed they'd push the price down what is
the main driver if the only driver
around drug consumption price so this is
another reason for not legalizing well I
don't go out and and get drunk because
it's cheaper I I go I'll go and have a
pint because it's a Friday night and I
wanna and you can afford and you can
afford a pint and the reason you drink
the amount of pints you drink is because
they don't cost 50 Quid a time if
they've got 50 Quid a time you drink
this pints that's a fact okay yeah so
the point is this so you then you
legalize you get this legal Market you
get an illegal market and the illegal
Market grows because people move from
something that doesn't really affect
them to someone that kicks their ass and
drugs is about an effect so you have to
go in that direction that's my first
thing it does not eliminate the legal
market and the legal Market has all
manner of sex trade involved violence
involved non-tax paying and I bring up
the non-tax paying bit because the other
thing is right I grew up with a lot of
people who dealt drugs like mostly just
so they didn't have to pay for their own
one or two people I knew along the way
were proper drug dealers and I remember
bumping into one of them and we were
talking about legalization and he said
to me Sean do you think I'm going to
stop selling drugs just because it's
legal he said are you mad
of course I'm not
he said I'll just sell more he says for
instance the people who Supply me yeah
Supply me at a very low rate a legal
business could never match what I'm
getting it for
I'll start selling
I'll start saying and how many legal
businesses are going to question me is
where I got my [ __ ] from and I use those
words because words he used well I got
my [ __ ] from now okay it's making money
don't care so come back to the illegal
Market we had Prohibition in this
country and we're Prohibition in the
United States there's been a lot of
Hollywood movies made about that is
there an illegal market and alcohol in
America that's worth talking about no
but what happens with alcohol is very
important that you compare apples and
apples what happened with alcohol it
became legal right it was it was then
pursued by the biggest at the time some
of the biggest businesses in the world
it pushed the price down so far it
became culturally acceptable and
everybody drunk it would you want that
situation with weed I'd rather more I'd
rather people smoke weed than drank
alcohol that's for sure that might
that's a whole other debate but the
point is alcohol is
um much less uh physically effective
um defective rather than than than weed
like you people there's people now
watching this who have a glass of wine
every night it probably make them live
longer yeah it's people who watch you
now who collect whiskey drink the
whiskey happy fine there's very few
people who smoke weed but it hasn't had
an effect on them there's very few
people who smoke the same amount of weed
now that they did when they started yeah
and why would you roll the dice with
um young People's Health and I give you
something that's a bit more of analogy
because it's modern look at vaping
right the amount of young people that
are vaping is skyrocketed skyrocketed
why because it's cheap because it's
marketed to them it's marketed to them
they can get older and let's be clear
they're not it's illegal for them to
have but they can get hold of it so if
you give people cheap legal drugs they
will smoke cheap legal drugs which
destroys their mental health destroys
their lungs generates mad amounts of
crime because remember that what we
don't know about alcohol is how much
crime you know theft burglary alcohol
drives right we probably know a little
bit less about that than we do about how
much
um like we class A drugs drives here
you'd massively be ramping that up and
that's before you get into the real
thing for me Mental Health
Sean this is my this is why people go
are you a conservator I'm not because
what I find funny about conservatives is
you guys you you're all into human
nature until it hits things like this
right because here's the human nature
argument on on this issue is people are
always going to do something to change
to alter their state of mind agreed
right agreed and to me it's about what
is it that you're allowing them to
consume if we're talking about the level
of the government that that you're doing
and as you said yourself alcohol is the
most damaging it's because it's the most
widely used but also it is much worse
for you than something like weed no it's
not yeah it is no it's not of course it
is it's not physically it's much worse
no it's not alcohol is no it's not look
to to my brother died of alkalism let's
me my brother drank himself to death it
took a very
very long time for that to happen and
the reason it took so long
um is because alcohol affects the news
lower level basically your body can deal
with it for longer I was a youth worker
for 30 years I watched boys
destroy their mental health by puffing
and so there's two levels of destroyment
of one was psychosis like yeah
I I could I can remember I can think of
at least four individuals that I
directly worked with who this is a word
a sort of Street type news who are now
walking up and down the High Street with
straws up their nose like you know you
know visibly in mental distress
right and then there's a much much
bigger crowd that lost any ability to
push on in life so they're what I call
the four o'clock boys they stay up till
four sleep till four only action is to
come out and get some weed and I
remember I had one boy in particular
right I I won't you I I I make up a name
for the right course of him and
he um he's got in trouble with the
police because he stole something's not
a thief he's not a thief like he wasn't
but he stole something it's
opportunities though
that money
I said at least 50 of that was going to
end up as weed and he looked at me right
he's about he's about to give me both
barrels and then he sort of went
[ __ ] you're right and I said that's why
I called it a crackhead move because we
don't associate weed with poor Behavior
we don't link the poor behavior that it
drives when someone takes crack we link
it much more easily yeah but we leave
and I said to him look your income needs
and I go back to something I said
probably half an hour ago one of the
ways to raise your income is to lower
your outgoings yeah your income needs a
significantly higher why because you
smoke weed I don't have a goal that I
worked with and her mum was constantly
trying to kick out her brother right he
joined our football team got into his
Fitness stopped puffing why so I started
bumping his sister every now and then
much less agitated much less chatting
about her brother how's it going bro
yeah it's all right she's all right it's
all right it's good it's all right so
all right what's changed you said I
don't know
and I said to him what's changed he said
yeah parent
so I said so I said boy you've got to go
to I used to run a job Club so I said
well you've got a job he said no no no
but I I he said I've just got a little
cash into like I'm going to House of pay
rent my mom choose me like a big man
because I'm paying rent so I'm cool
she's great but it's cool so I said to
him how you pay rent and he said yeah
because I don't burn anymore
I don't bump see and we're not we're not
making those connections and I make
those connections because I saw it
happening and the only difference
between me and the people I grew up with
is I don't smoke and don't drink
I used to ask a couple of questions like
why I mean but are you making my point
which is you are voluntarily choosing
not to smoke or drink and drinking is
legal yeah and you make my point right
human nature you said because sometimes
are not into human nature but human
nature exists and the point is this at
some point yeah you have to intervene
because we all pay the bill yeah when so
many people have a a a a a breakdown
like yeah I agree with you on the menu I
agree we'll all end up paying for the
mental health we'll all end up paying
for the physical health in the NHS and
we'll all end up paying for the police
Health we'll pick what I don't
understand is in in a world where
alcohol is legal and it's perfectly
acceptable in this country and as a
Russian boy even as a Russian that
buckles my mind how much drink how much
people drink here but right that's
perfectly socially acceptable your guy
from the building side who gets drug
tested every day could be smashing 10
pints every night yeah but he can't come
to work drunk that's the first thing you
can't come to work drunk but you could
be smashing 10 points waking up the next
day and going to work and he could say
to his boss I sunk 10 last night and
they'd all laugh and high five but the
difference with alcohol is this is a
very important point when somebody
Compares that and now I know they're
desperately just trying to legalize
drugs alcohol is historic when we
invented alcohol right we thought people
were witches
in fact we invented alcohol before we
invented which is it is alcohol is
literally ancient we didn't know and I
go back to your point which I think is
very true people will always seek to get
out of their mind somehow right you know
some people do bass jumping some people
drink whiskey yeah right you can't take
it all away so we historically have
alcohol let's try to control that keep a
little and deal it we don't need to add
to that part that will just be my take
don't get me wrong I go with a lot of
people who puff all the while yeah and
they're fine they're fine
to a certain extent lead them to it but
don't grow that group because an
exponential growth in that group means
an exponential growth in people whose
lives are destroyed because of it and
Sean what would you say we've touched on
it briefly about the illegal activity by
legalizing these drugs you take it away
from The Gangs you disrupt their
business model
and you know you can tax it you make
income off it surely it's a win-win no
it isn't you Legalize It you don't take
it away from the gangs what you do is
give them a much much bigger Market
nowhere in the world is illegal Market
gone away what you then do is you
provide a waiting room for their
activity so if I'm smoking with the
government basically give me Men full
cigarettes right I then meet said drug
deal in a rave or my local park and he
said you smoke that crap I'll give you
something that really upset you alike oh
my gosh yes you go there you go there
and that's before you get into wood drug
dealers then try to seek out legitimate
business and short-circuit that
situation like bruv you see how much
you're paying for your weed yeah
to protects I don't know I remember part
of life we it's a cash business yeah
how's the government know how much use
you put through the doors this week I
ain't got a coupon I'll get you we don't
buy that you're buying stuff from Union
either when you can buy stuff from Derek
coming man Derek set you up properly
that's what would happen and and anybody
who doubts me look what happens to all
the calves in Amsterdam what happened in
um in Canada all these places that's
what happens you know drug dealers are
some of the most inventive Fearless
entrepreneurs in the world I wish it
wasn't the way but they are they are
clever people they and those and they
won't cease to be clever just because
you've legalized so let's find a way to
wrap the sub then Sean in a way that
we're not still arguing uh but I
actually really respect the conversation
and enjoy it
how do we solve the problem of I mean
because look from the sort of like
middle class Suburbia point of view the
way London looks to a lot of people now
is it's just endless people running
around with [ __ ] machetes
around the Streets of London right like
how how do we deal with that look
it is still a small enough group of
people doing that mostly around Street
Life drug going on I noticed I didn't
use the word gangs gang behavior is part
of it but it isn't all of it I don't
want anybody to just write off it's just
gangs there's more to it than that
um but the number is still small enough
for us to get on top of it okay London
is still one of the safest bigger cities
in the world that is a fact and um but
boy it needs to be safer for sure right
particularly for people who live here if
you live here and you live in certain
places in London it's very easy to get
caught up in it so we do need to work on
it and it it it it the technical
approach would be this we need to have a
plan to get more and more weapons off
the street we need to make it there if
you've got a knife you feel that
someone's going to find out you feel
nervous about it that's the first thing
because that just lowers the opportunity
for people to be stabbed it lowers the
opportunity for someone to escalate and
a stabbing happen right I I dealt with a
boy recently who had stabbed someone and
he said to me wish he never had his life
on him
I said why is it without an actual
nothing would happen and he said now I'm
sitting in jail like it's a Madness I
said but you stop and say yeah I know
Sean but he's saying I'm having to think
how I he said Innovation I did it to
myself which was a mad admission you
know I mean
so that that's sort of where I've come
from there like get those weapons off
the street
the other pieces as well
you have certain communities who've been
under such pressure for such a long time
always talked about as victims who have
who have been victimized so have become
victims we need to give them a break and
a break generally means their young
people having some kind of future and I
want to be really clear about it it's
not youth work I've been a youth worker
for 30 years in my opinion it's
employment yeah there is no Silver
Bullet to this youth rock is brilliant I
believe in youth work I've given more
than half my life over to youth work
yeah but youth work is like an
entertainment yes it can do serious
things I've done family therapy I've run
job clubs look they can do serious
things but what you want is people to be
independent of youth work if you look at
the communities doing the best in London
their children don't do youth work don't
go to youth work they do other things so
youth work needs to be as a channel to
drop and I just say a job a job is not
to be all in it or anything but it does
some very important things it gives
people a wider Network
it gives them access to finance and is
wonderful for their confidence
I I've talked about white mccaskill
let's be very clear I respect the middle
classes because what they do is take
responsibility work and even the guilt
part is them trying to sort of say to
people we want to help we've done well
we want to see you do well I I get it
but ask yourself this are you preventing
a group of people developing the skills
to have something to teach their
children
I mean are you trying to parachute
yourselves in I mean how comes poor
immigrants communities have done
completely well before they got here
like our parents done a massive thing
making the transition here it's a
massive thing and strong communities
what they need is opportunity they don't
need to be um
actualized they need opportunity and and
then when you talk about opportunity
people then have to realize opportunity
um the quality of opportunity is
different to a quality of outcome a
quality of outcome is impossible yeah
right you know your cameraman's a better
cameraman than me he will get that
cameraman job yeah right so what you're
trying to do is give people some kind of
road map to some kind of opportunity
that they believe and they can move on
because what that does that transforms
their community over the long term and
then I have things that I am
particularly passionate about that other
people are somewhere on a spectrum I
think for instance the prevalence of
marriage
is needs to be up and someone said to me
it's just a piece of paper and yeah he
is just a piece of paper but it is a
fact that married people live longer are
happier their children have better ml is
a fact the institutional marriage does
something to somebody's expectations and
their output so we should we should do
more than that and of course where
children are concerned married people
make more money that you know even more
than cohabiting people and married
people break up three times less than
God have it in people that's really
important and and when you speak to
Children the biggest thing that drives
their mental health is their um
orientation and their parents their
parents the government mental health is
bad that's not my opinion happens to be
a fact and I don't say that to make
people feel bad I don't say that to
people I have to say together don't stay
together one of the things I think that
makes marriage valuable is no fault
divorce if I had a magic wand one of the
first things I'd fix is you should be
able to divorce someone and only have to
find who was at fault you shouldn't stay
with people if you don't want to but if
more people had an expectation to stay
together more people would stay together
it's gonna sound bizarre but Finland of
shoulders that the government is
supporting marriage in many way their
marriage rates have gone through the
roof and their social output is also
going for the roof but that's just
something that I'm remember I come from
a single parent family so that's and and
I've watched my community
just be destroyed by drugs and and poor
educational attainment and and gangs and
and and fatherlessness and my overriding
thing I'd say last is do not rely on
politicians to fix your world I know you
think you're not but every time you ask
what the government is doing that's
basically doing that try to find
something in your personal life and your
family life and your broader community
life does something positive and beyond
that join a Civic organization a charity
a think tank that's doing the thinking
that's how we fit the country not
waiting for the for politicians
politicians are very important to have
something to do and we and we have the
right to push them and cajole them to do
it and do that but but don't rely on
that and the last thing I'd say is be
wary of what you read and who you
believe
one of the best conversations I've had
recently is a woman who only knows about
me in her words through the guardian
right so we had this long conversation
you know up and down we disagreed we
agreed I mean we literally hugged at the
bus stop she said oh it's been
stimulated you know she said you're a
teeny bit wrong about her yeah I know
your TV I mean your high five Target is
wonderful and she said now I know where
I know your name I read about you she
said you're the guy I ran for mayor of
London so remember we spoke for like a
clear 25 minutes before we reached that
point and she said you're nothing like
how they painted you in the press and
the one thing I'd say to the country we
are being so handled by the Press now of
course I'm about to tell you what being
particularly handled by the left-wing
press that that's my particular sort of
orientation but we've been handled by
the press and the best people in the
world the most formative people in the
world are the people who question the
people who test not cynics but triers I
live a puddly in the other day and he
gave me a term GLT and I was like what's
that he said God loves the trial he said
get out there and keep trying and that's
what you've got to do you've got you
trying to grow your your intellect your
physical self your your relationships
around you grow the young people around
you and so I keep having the last thing
this is my last last week someone said
to me you know surely did you fought for
years what what what's the best thing
you can do for a young person Inspire
them a young person is inspired will
never need pushing never need and you
don't know and I'm trying to do my own
son now and my daughter it's been a bit
easy with my daughter because she's 15
she's got a Clear Vision of the world my
son's only 13. but if you have any young
people in your world help them figure
out what they like
and what they enjoy slightly two
different things because enjoy for me
has a little bit more activity you're
doing a thing because if you can help a
child figure that out you can help them
build a future you know you can get them
to turn up for themselves
but I'm going to stop because
Sean it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you so much for coming on the show
if people want to find you online where
is the best place to do that I am Sean
Bailey am on Twitter I'm on Instagram
um my Twitter has a little bit of
Politics on it because you know I'm in
politics my Instagram is just me and my
kids doing stuff but it's much more
funny I'm nasty action there and I'm out
I'm in the Press I do GB news regularly
I want to download and show I'm very
regularly and I'll just try to keep it a
public eye and have the conversation and
I'm constantly looking for ways to help
people be independent that that for me
is is the goal well Sean we're going to
ask you a couple of questions for all my
supporters that only they will get to
see but as always the last question we
always ask on the show is what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
foreign
the state of education we are not
we use school to train and to be
training is different to education and
we no longer use University to discuss
we are teaching our children to Define
themselves as One Singular thing and
then to hate anybody that isn't them and
that is the quickest way to destroy your
country
very well said Sean thank you so much
for coming on and thank you for watching
and listening we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or our show all of them go at 7 pm
UK time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
will Sean be standing for mayor again he
did better than expected last time or
will he be looking to run for MP maybe
replacing Rosendale
[Music]